the parents hadn't found here invite
fatal in the forest water in Lower
Austria and also I wanted to stay I want
to do the six different way my name is
Jonas Goodman i'm the founder and
director with organic herb tea in spice
company what we do is we grow and
collect products from over 150 organic
farmers with package and sell them under
one friend sustainable original
development is key to our policy to
support small rural structures which
have a long tradition in valley village
for us the 2004 EU enlargement was a
milestone in our development we already
had a subsidiary in czech republic since
92 but with water restrictions gun both
companies could grow much faster in the
past 10 years the number of our
employees has risen from 45 to 225 in
austria and from 2285 in czech republic
since 2004 we can also export to all new
member states and we buy a lot from them
too
relations have really developed over
time and enlargement is very much
contributed to a better mutual
understanding trust and appreciation